our top story this hour keeping up the
pressure on Syria President Trump's
decision to attack a Syrian Air Base is
getting widespread praise from other
nations and the u.s. is warning that
it's prepared to take further military
or economic measures against Syria mr.
Trump is spending the weekend in Florida
White House correspondent Margaret
Brennan is in Palm Beach with more
Margaret good morning good morning
president Trump has had a busy past few
days hosting foreign leaders and
completely up ending his America first
foreign policy with this decision to
carry out a limited military strike in
Syria 59 Tomahawk cruise missiles were
launched from two US warships in the
Mediterranean Sea and the target was a
Syrian airfield from which it's believed
the Assad regime launched Tuesday's
sarin gas attack US officials estimate
20 aircraft were destroyed ammunition
doves and radars were also hit now the
Syrian and Russian government have
publicly decried the missile strikes and
deny that any chemical weapons were used
but during the presidential campaign it
was President Trump himself who said he
opposed a deeper involvement in the six
year old Syrians war aides now say the
president was outraged after he saw
those images of small children choking
to death on poison gas that led him to
completely reverse his position and less
than three days later he authorized this
missile strike now the attack may have
also undercut one of mr. Trump's foreign
policy goals that's to forge friendlier
relations with Russia on Friday Russian
President Vladimir Putin called the
American military operation a violation
of international law and a significant
blow to already fractured us-russian
relations now yesterday the
administration announced that new
sanctions are coming on the Assad regime
and Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
heads next week to Russia where he is
expected to meet with Vladimir Putin to
discuss Syria
Alex Margaret Brennan and Palm Beach
thanks Margaret